[موسيقى]
بالقرب من خرسون من الممكن رؤيه اثار
القصف الروسي على مدى اميال لكن مدعين
عامين يبحثون عن اثار اعمق لا تظهر على
السطح وبعضها لم يعد موجودا بعد احتلال
موسكو للمدينه الاوكرانيه لثمانيه اشهر
انا نائب المدعيه العامه ومهمه اجراء
التحقيق قبل المحاكمه وتطبيق الاحكام
المتعلقه بالقضايا الجنائيه في قسم جرائم
العنف الجنسي
اخفينا هويه الرجال منهم هذا المحامي الذي
اعتقلته القوات الروسيه في الشارع يوم
السابع من ايلول سبتمبر يتذكر تفاصيل
احتجازه بحرقه
على مدى 20 دقيقه تقريبا كانوا يضربونني
بالعصي ويسعقونني بالكهرباء على ظهري
ومؤخره وساقي وعندما اسقط يصرخون علي كي
اقف ويهينونني بالقول هل تنتظر رسول الجيش
الاوكراني قبل ان يسعقوني بالكهرباء مره
اخرى
[موسيقى]
انه احتجز لاكثر من اسبوعا في زنزانه لا
تتجاوز مساحتها سته امتار مربعه برفقه
ثمانيه اخرين وانه تعرض للتعذيب لثلاثه
ايام
مولدا كهربائيا وثبت قطبيه بعضو التناسلي
فيما كانت يدايه مثبتتين خلفي برباط
بلاستيكي ثم بداوا بتدوير مقبض المولد
وكلما اداروه اسرع كلما ازدادت شده
الكهرباء وبالتالي يشتد الالم
كما يقول انا جلاديه لم يضربوه على وجهه
كلا يترك ندوبا عليه
كلما فتح باب الزنزانه كان علينا ان ننهض
ونصره المجد لروسيا المجد للبوتين المجد
للشويجو لكنني كنت افكر دائما بعائلتي
وزوجتي وطفلي وهذا ما كان يساعدني ويشجعني
على البقاء حيا
[موسيقى]
بعد اطلاق سراحه غير سرخي مكان سكنه ورقم
هاتفه ويعيش حاليا حاله من الارتياب عندما
استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه خرسون في تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر الماضي اتصلت به الشرطه
ليدلي بشهادته على اعتبار ان العنف الجنسي
لا يقتصر على الاغتصاب كما انه لا يتعلق
بالمراه فقط
احتلال جزء من الاقليم عام 2014 ورفق ذلك
العديد من اعمال التعذيب خاصه على الاعضاء
التناسليه للرجال وهذا ما لوحظ في جميع
مراكز الاحتجاز في المحتله في خرسون تتكرر
الحالات وخاصه صعق الاعضاء التناسليه
للرجال بالكهرباء وفي كثير من الاحيان
يترافق التعذيب مع عبارات مثل هكذا لن
تتمكن من انجاب اطفال
منذ شباط فبراير العمل الماضي يحقق القسم
في عشرات الجرائم الجنسيه المحتمله ثمان
وثلاثون ارتكبت ضد الرجال وما خفي اعظم
بحسب اندريه
لماذا لا يتعذر علينا الوصول الى بعض
الاماكن التي اعتقل فيها الناس بشكل غير
قانوني وبعضها تم تدميره وبهذا فقدنا ادله
محتمله كثيره
كل شخص لديه تصوره عن الواقع وهذه الحالات
تحصل ضمن الظروف مرهقه ولا سيما واننا في
حاله حرب
اخر هو ان هذه الاعمال قد تحدث في زنازين
اخرى او ان الشخص لا يتذكر جيدا ملامح وجه
من اعتدى عليه
يعتمد المحققون على شهادات مرتبطه بهذه
الجرائم وخاصه عندما تتضمن تفاصيل دقيقه
وهذا ما ينطبق على هذا الجندي الذي احتجز
الصيف الماضي
كنت مع رفاقه الزنزانه اخرجهم الجنود
الروس الى الممر ووضعوا واقيه ذكريه على
هروات واغتصبوهم بها واجبرون على المشاهده
كانوا ستكون التاره ان لم تخبرنا بمكان
مستودعات الاسلحه ومكان رفاقك اغتصبوا احد
رفاق ليومين ثم اعطوه الواقي الذكري الذي
استعملوه قبل ان يجبروه على اخراجه من
جيبه ومضغه امامهم
يتم الحصول على المعلومات احيانا من مقاطع
مصوره يرسلها السجنون الى اقاربهم وهذا
يساعد في التحقيقات
كنا نرى وجوههم احيانا دون اقنعه على مدى
ثلاثه ايام اقتدوا جميع المحتجزين الى
طابق سفلي وعذبون طوال الليل
ينتهي الحال ببعض الشهود الى الاقرار
بانهم هم ايضا ضحايا للعنف الذي يصفونه
خلال ذلك يسعى المحققون الى دعم الناجين
في مسار تعافيهم ويحاولون تاسيس قضايا
بادله قويه ضد القوات الروسيه العمل
الماضي عينت ارينا ديدينكو مدعيه عامه
مسؤوله عن قسم العنف الجنسي المرتبط
بالنزاع تعمل من حينها على ضمان ان تكون
التحقيقات سليمه ودقيقه
بانفسنا عن روسيا لكوننا على استعداد
للتحقيق في ايه جريمه ومن الضروري التمييز
بين الجريمه العاديه وجريمه الحرب توجهنا
الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في لاهاي
واجرينا مشاورات حول كيفيه تنظيم
التحقيقات بشكل صحيح بحيث يتم تسجيلها
لتتوافق مع المؤسسات الدوليه مهمتنا هي
ضمان ان تكون جميع تحقيقاتنا شفافه وان
تجرى وفق حكم القانون نسعى في اوكرانيا
الى وضع بوتين امام العداله فنحن جميعا
نعلم من هو المسؤول عما يجري
يسعى المحققون الاوكرانيون الى الكشف عن
جرائم حرب محتمله ومرتكبيها المزعومين
امام العالم اجمع ومن ثم تقديمهم امام
العداله